[Music]
it's
intensely contemplative
it is almost hypnotic
it's like putting your hand on the
third rail of the universe
if you play go seriously there is a
chance that you will
get exposed to this
experience that is kind of like nothing
else
on the planet go is putting you in a
place
where you're always at the very
farthest reaches of your capacity
there's a reason that people have been
playing go for thousands and thousands
of years right
it's not just that they want to
understand go
they want to understand what
understanding is
and maybe that is truly what it means to
be human
i was a kid i loved playing games
i started off with board games like
chess
and then i bought my first computer when
i was eight with winnings from a chess
tournament
ever since then i felt that computers
were this sort of magical device
that could extend the power of your mind
virtual environments and games we think
they're the perfect platform for
developing and testing ai algorithms
games are very convenient in that a lot
of them have scores
so it's very easy to measure incremental
progress
so i'm going to show you a few videos of
the agent system
the ai so let's start off with breakout
so here you control the baton ball
and you're trying to break through this
rainbow colored wall the agent system
has to learn everything for itself
just from the raw pixels doesn't know
what it's controlling
it doesn't even know what the object of
the game is now the beginning after 100
games
um you can see the agent is not very
good it's missing the ball most of the
time
but it's time to get the hang of the
idea that the bat should go towards the
ball
now after 300 games it's about as good
as any human can play this
and pretty much gets the ball back every
time we thought well that's pretty cool
but we left the
system playing for another 200 games and
it did this amazing thing it found the
optimal strategy was to dig a tunnel
around the side
and put the ball around the back of the
wall the researchers working on this
amazing ai developers
but they're not so good at breakouts and
they didn't know about that strategy so
they learned something from their own
system which is
uh you know pretty funny and quite
instructive i think about
the potential for general ai so for us
what's the next step now
go is the most complex game pretty much
ever devised by man
beating a professional player at go is a
long-standing
grand challenge of ai research
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
when i was 18 i won't change my life
this is why i go to french i won't
try to forget the goal
but it's impossible because all the
things i learned
in my life is this visco
it looks like a mirror i see the goal i
also see
myself for me gold is a real
life
[Music]
dear mr pham my name is demyster harbis
i run an artificial intelligence company
based in london called deepmind
as the strongest go player in europe we
would like to invite you to our offices
in london
both to meet you in person and to share
with you an exciting go project that we
are working on
if you would be interested in coming to
visit us please let us know
any thanks kind regards demis
when i see this email i don't know it's
true or not well i will accept about
this
why not for me
iris is an adventure i want to go to
visit deepmind to know what is
this go project
[Music]
the first visit i think maybe i want me
sit in the special room push many many
wear
in my hand also my body let me play
to scan my spring i don't know
to make some research we needed to get
fan way to
deep mind to see we were a serious
operation and we were serious people
um doing proper research
and the search time is getting better
and better like as we go from for
example one to eight in any one of these
it always go goes up we think of deep
mind as
kind of like an apollo program effort
for ai
our mission is to fundamentally
understand intelligence
and recreate it artificially and then
once we've done that we feel that we can
use that technology to help society
solve all sorts of other problems if we
step through the actual game we can
see kind of what alphago thinks what's
the most likely variation that he thinks
will happen
we've been working on alphago our
program to play go for
just under two years now all the little
patterns cascade together
layer after layer after layer after
layer
i started talking about the game of go
with demis more than 20 years ago
and so this has been a really long
journey the game of go is the holy grail
of artificial intelligence
for many years people have looked at
this game and they've thought
wow this is just too hard everything
we've ever tried in ai
it just falls over when you try the game
of go and so that's why it feels like a
real litmus test of progress
if we can crack go we know we've done
something special
so with fan hurry we started talking
around what the real purpose of the
visit was
it wasn't just a go project we wanted
him to help with that actually we wanted
to play him
and we had a very strong program oh it's
okay just the program is so easy
so we'll be easy to play a lot of people
have thought that it was decades away
some people thought it would be never
because
they felt that to succeed at go you
needed
human intuition go is the
world's oldest continuously played board
game
and in some sense it is one of the
simplest
and also most abstract there's only one
type of piece there's only one type of
move you just place that piece on the
board
and then your goal is to create a
linked group of your stones that
surrounds some empty territory
and when you surround enemy stones you
capture them
and remove them from the board you earn
points by
surrounding territory and at the end of
the game the person
with the most territory wins it seems
really simple
but then you sit down to play and you
realize right away it's like well
i technically know what i'm allowed to
do but i have no clue what i should do
go's incredibly challenging for
computers to tackle because
compared to say chess the number of
possible moves in a position
is much larger in chess it's about 20.
in go it's about 200
and a number of possible configurations
of the board is more than the number of
atoms in the universe
so even if you took all the computers in
the world and ran them for a million
years
that wouldn't be enough compute power to
calculate all the possible variations
if you ask a great go player why they
played a particular move
sometimes they'll just tell you it felt
right so we have to come up with some
kind of
clever algorithm to mimic what people do
with their intuition
nice to meet you hello so with fan
hurray we agreed
a best of five match and we agreed it
would be filmed
you know we will treat it as a serious
match
i play with alphago aja hwang push the
stone
for alphago and of course i think i will
win the game with alphago because it's
just a program
[Music]
the first game i make some mistake
and i lose again
in that first match i think something
clicked for him that
this wasn't an ordinary go program we
weren't just doing the
the same as everyone else that something
new was happening
the second game i try to change my style
but the problem is also i lose the
second game
and also for third game first game
even the last game i lose
five zero
alpha go win all the game after
losing losing losing you can feel his
pressure is getting
heavier and heavier and several times
after the game he said
he wanted to go out for fresh air
i said oh i can go with you and have a
chat he said no i want to go myself
i feel something very strange
i lose this program and i don't
understand myself anymore
i worried whether he'd even come back
you know
he seemed very low and he spent about an
hour away from the office he came back
completely changed
i thought maddie this is the first time
in the history
the human professional gold player lose
with the program she tell me yes we know
but for you i do i okay
i told her
not and yes i
am not happy to lose the game but
i'm very will be happy for play in the
history
artificial intelligence researchers has
solved the game of
go a decade earlier than expected the
computer named alphago was able to beat
the european
human champion artificial intelligence
researchers have made a significant
breakthrough
it really is a big leap forward there's
a big difference between
the way the ibm computer beats kasparov
which was programmed by expert chess
players and the way
the go playing computer more or less
learned itself
the way we start off training alphago is
by showing it a hundred thousand
games that strong amateurs have played
that we've downloaded from the internet
and we first initially get alphago to
mimic the human player
and then through self-playing
reinforcement learning it plays against
different versions of itself many
millions of times and learns from its
errors
these specific ideas that are driving
alphago
are going to drive our our future the
technologies at the heart
of alphago they're what are called deep
neural networks which essentially
mimic the web of neurons in the human
brain it's a very old idea
but recently due to increases in
computing power
these neural networks have become
extremely powerful almost overnight big
neural networks that
operate on big data can achieve
surprising things
alphago found a way to learn how to play
go learning is the key thing here it's
machine learning
the whole beauty of these types of
algorithms is that because they're
learning for themselves they can go
beyond what we as the programmers know
how to do
and allow us to make new breakthroughs
in areas of science and medicine
so alphago is one significant step
towards that
ultimate goal
my wife called me she told me don't
see internet don't connect internet
because
people talk terrible thing about you
much with olivago
fanue is living so long time in europe
it's not real professional he's just an
amateur player
this is so hard for me so hard
the go world were skeptical about how
strong really was alphago
and how much further did it need to get
to be the top professionals
so our program is improving over time
and
we want to push the ai algorithm to the
limit and see how far
this kind of self-improving process can
go
so we needed to look for an even greater
challenge
a match like no other is about to get
underway in south korea
lee c dole will be long-reigning
alphago and the ultimate human versus
machine
smackdown this is a huge moment for both
the world of artificial intelligence
and i think the world of go so far
alphago has beaten every challenge we've
given it
but we won't know its true strength
until we play somebody who is at the top
of the world
likely to don we chose lisa dole because
he wanted a legendary historic player
somebody who has been acknowledged as
the greatest player of the last decade
i will not be too arrogant but i don't
think that it will be a very close match
the level of the player that africa went
against in october is not the same level
as me
so given that a couple of months was
only passed
i don't think that it is enough for it
to be able to catch up with me
my hope is that it will be either five
zero for me
or maybe four to one so the critical
point for me is to make sure i do not
lose one
higher we don't know
how well our system will play against
someone as
creative as lisa doll also he's very
famous for
very creative um fighting play yeah so
this could be um difficult for us but
we'll see maybe in some ways he's the
most difficult opponent we can take
there was still so much of a question
about whether or not
they could beat someone like lee sedol
von way is a good player but he's
nothing like
the very top players he said all is a
nine down professional
nine don professional is the highest
rank that you can achieve and go
the ranking system fanfare who's the
european champion
is just a two don professional on the
other hand
the very top he said all is nine down
professional
they said all is to go what roger
federer is to tennis he's
playing in wimbledon to win the grand
slam and it's not just this year he'll
be there next year and the year after
that
and the year after that of course in
internet
and all the gold community everyone
maybe not 100 maybe 99.99
think listener will win very easy
[Music]
[Music]
go is taken seriously in korea it's so
much part of the culture like breathing
or you know like
taking swimming lessons or something on
the surface is a game
but inside had a very deep philosophy
goalboard reflects the individual who's
playing
the true gonna show itself on the board
you won't be able to hide it
in ancient china japan korea
go is one of the four noble things
like for accomplishment for literacy
with music poetry and painting
so people think the go players
are very smart and very noble uh
[Music]
master guan started this school so that
he could
produce great prayer in korea he said
when he was age of eight he came in here
attending class 9 a.m till 9 p.m
seven days and then he stayed with the
master one
already
was a little boy that i remember when i
was a student
studying go he was very young and
rural enough to think that pizza grew on
trees
[Music]
plays things that are interesting where
you felt
like he's beyond winning and losing he
wants to do something that's
innovative or takes things to the next
level so every go player
started his game for sure roughly 10
years he dominates the
professional gold world he win 18 world
championships
[Music]
definitely lizard is going to win the
game 5-0
yeah all game it's gonna win all game
we had our evaluation match last week we
won a game
and we lost a game and we lost the game
in a way that would have made us look
extremely foolish if that happened
publicly it means that we still have
work to do
and we need to take this really
seriously it's just too much risk that
actually we could we could lose overall
not only that but we could lose in a way
that makes us look rather silly
so i guess um yeah i did you want to say
anything about what you're trying
i'm walking home
so we're working around the clock at the
moment training our algorithms further
trying to incrementally keep on
improving right up to the moment where
we have the match
we've collected together people with
different skill sets
onto the same team so we have
researchers engineers
evaluation guys that you mean what
happens if they create something new
which wasn't used
then we don't see it okay the first
thing to know is things can help the
perfect solution
is the leaf programmer and built the
original search engine
so address responsibility is quite a big
one he will be the one
sitting opposite lisa dole and actually
playing the moves
alphago makes i'm feeling excited yeah
at least i know he's a great player and
i feel honored to play with him
many of my friends they are very excited
about match they
keep telling me that the whole world is
watching
just prepare alphago hello
hello dennis can you hear us yes i can
hear you guys can you hear me okay
yes perfect i was curious to meet you
such an amazing developer who made
alphago
it's very nice to meet you thank you
thank you likewise um
it's a real pleasure to meet you um i
love
the game of go i'm not very good but i
don't know if you know
um but we actually have something in
common
i actually also i'm trained at a game at
a young age
i used to be when i was young
professional chess player
i used to play for the england team
and then i stopped playing when i was
about 14. i was um
when i was 13 i was the second highest
rated player in the world
after the match i would like to propose
that i give you one teaching game of go
and you give me one teaching game of
chess
that sounds very good i would be very
honored to to do that
i'm not sure if it's okay to ask you
this question
but i saw the games against fanfuy and i
didn't think
it was quite at the level to play with
me
but i heard that it's getting really
stronger
can i ask how much it got stronger um
yeah i i i can't say too much of course
but it's definitely got uh significantly
stronger
well with more time i think a logical
approach would be to follow up on
ash's local search and run that in fast
alpha
and generate a whole new data set and
iterate for more time
but we're just out of time we realized
that if we wanted to prepare for
a mammoth task like taking on lisa dole
there would be nothing better than
talking to a professional and we
couldn't have picked a better person
than fanway
we invite him as an advisor because
during the match we found he is a man of
good spirit
welcome back thank you very much he's
very precious that we have fun
with us
he was crushed by avago but then he
became very positive and
a big help to us when them has tell me
can you come back to help us make africa
more stronger
and feel this respect of course i
accept about this
i play with alphago to understand
where is the strong point about alphago
and
where is baby the weakness
i play this morning afternoon
all the time and i found something
i found big weakness about alphago
the big one the superheroes always have
a hidden vulnerability
right and the same is true of alphago
it's unbelievably superhuman in general
but it has some particular weaknesses in
some situations
we can think of there being this space
of all the things it knows about
and it knows about most of it extremely
well but then there'll be these tricky
lumps of knowledge
that it just understands very poorly and
it's really hard for us to characterize
when it's going to enter into one of
these lumps
but if it does it can be completely
delusional thinking that it's alive on
one part of the board when in fact it's
dead or vice versa
so there is a real risk that we could
lose the match
everybody in the team try to work more
and more to fix the problem but
i think it's difficult to fix this very
quickly we've got version 18 in the
pipeline haven't we
well we'll only go for verse 19 if it
makes it significant if it doesn't
which were having to rerun all the tests
because they
um they went wrong unfortunately so
we're sort of basically a day behind in
our evaluation because of that
all the confidence well maybe we just
need to be realistic that we've tried a
bunch of things
and we've come to the point where we
said we would actually start freezing
the code and
saying look it's
not and actually not panning out these
delusions are still
a realistic possibility for the match we
have some weaknesses
that we i don't think we're going to fix
fully um
before the match so um that's causing us
a little bit of anxiety
[Music]
fleecy doll is getting ready to rumble
on wednesday
live across the internet this
professional south korean go player will
take on
artificial intelligence program alphago
tomorrow julian and george they pack up
version 18
they stick it on a laptop and they fly
out to seoul
[Music]
[Music]
when i get to the hotel i'm going to
catch up with the team what we should do
in the time remaining is
list things that could go wrong in the
solidity of the system
[Applause]
in a difficult situation he likes to
smoke yes there is terrace
and we'll have security so he'll be able
to go up then be by himself
when i got here i didn't expect the
attention on the match it was
literally front page news about eight
million
koreans play the game of go and even
those who don't you know recognize lee
sedol
he's a national figure and so there's
that
right there's some national pride
involved but it's more than that
just the very thought of a machine
playing a human
at something like this i think is
inherently intriguing to people
[Music]
all the world gave the pressure to
listen
before this he played the tournament for
country
for himself but this time he played for
the human
i just really hope we win this first
game if you lose the first game you
literally have to win three out of four
yeah which is hard work where are you
going to be
i'll start in the match room and then
i'm going to come in here make sure
everything's here yeah
you should probably be in here
hello and welcome to the deepmind
challenge
game one round one live from the four
seasons here
in seoul korea i am chris garlick of the
american go e-journal i'm here with
michael
redmond nine don professional welcome
michael i want to give a
shout out to all of the folks watching
around the world
well the excitement's pretty palpable
here in the hotel i've never seen a
crush of
interest to reporters from around the
world
all right folks you're here you're gonna
see history made stay with us
five minutes guys five minutes
i just thought we should take a moment
together
and just think about what's about to
happen
extremely excited to be there extremely
proud of every one of you and what we've
done
and we're no loss i think it's just
amazing that we're here
[Music]
okay
[Music]
so
[Music]
boys
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
oh thank you
we had worked so hard to make sure that
this would go
technically smoothly we tested it and
tested it and tested it
and still there comes that moment when
you're
live all the tv cameras are broadcasting
everything and now it has to do the
thing you built it to do
so
much
i was a bit nervous it's the first time
that i
sit in front of a world-class co-player
and i actually can feel the spirit and
courtesy of a great co-player
like lisa because i think it is the
first time he
faced a strange opponent i think he's
not a human
has no emotion it's cold but he
stays very calm and i can feel his
mental strength
[Music]
oh
[Music]
here is meow on kim uh nine don pro from
the korean baduk association
we are here live at the four seasons
hotel on the 21st floor
what are we looking at how's the game
going
oh it's fighting no from the beginning
from the very beginning
yeah yeah he i forgot place very well
yeah
just he's like a top professional just
like a top professional
yeah it's very aggressive
now the fight is getting really
complicated um this is actually the
first time i've seen alpha go
playing a game that has this difficult
fight
foreign
i just saw him looking at his opponent's
face and that's that's just a kind of a
habit
just an instinct as a player to look at
the person across it yeah
it's it's sort of like um something that
lisa though would do when he was
wondering
how his opponent was feeling right it's
just a just a habit
so it's not as if ajah huang is going to
do any giveaway because ajahn isn't
alphago right
oh
[Music]
linda
with human when you play you can have
exchange
by feeling i look in you i know okay
maybe you won't talk with me maybe you
fear about me
i can feel many many things but alphago
you can feel nothing so
when you confirm nothing when you play
you have a more than more question about
yourself
for beginning you think okay my move is
good and really
good really good oh maybe bad
oh terrible why would you hear more
and more it's hard to know where to be
all the different rooms are like
exciting a different way isn't it
to be here at the heart of the operation
yeah i feel
safe here white's thinking of doing this
huge invasion here from its thick wall
yes go for it it's done it's
[Music]
that is not a confident face he's pretty
uh horrified by that
i can't believe what i see right now oh
really
she thought you know she's a little bit
behind
and she made a very aggressive move here
okay make it very complicated
okay i think he said oh if he doesn't
know respond quickly
then he can collapse
i mean this one is kind of unthinkable
as a human group they are
what if she knows everything about
what's going to happen next
where are we here's our search terms
50 or 60 that's the maximum number of
moves ahead that alphago is looking
from the current game position it's
typically over 50 it's often over 60.
in the games we see often around 150
alpha go goes for the kill we're 100
move 115 now so
we're getting to that point
we are all astonished just in the middle
of the game
because although go is uh seems to be
doing a much better job than we all
thought it would
i thought they said all would be leading
the game
comfortably but it turned out that he's
struggling at the moment
but i think eventually he will prevail i
hope
i was uh you know more five to zero
but now i'm not sure about that
there might be the first mistake kind of
clear mistake that
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
why one or not at this time you check
this if it's like this white has won by
a lot yeah
wow it's so shocking i i expected
alphago to win only one
game
i can feel his pain like he was
he couldn't believe you know he couldn't
accept it it takes time
for him to accept the outcome
maybe alphago is very strong now but he
don't won't believe
heavy rules it's just the goal portion
player we
took we can't believe this because form
for us
is something very very far it's not
can be coming now it's impossible
but in reality it's not
i think he resigned in a very polite way
these are the he's black but he blew
white stone
i think he resigned
oh my gosh
oh yeah the time is stuck wow
i feel really good i feel like um i
i really believe in alphago of course
it's natural that humans want humans to
win i mean i think that's a natural
response
but alphago is human created and i think
that's the ultimate sign of human
ingenuity and cleverness everything that
alphago does
it does because a human has either
created the data that it learns from
created the learning algorithm that
learns from that data creates the search
algorithm
all of these things have come from from
humans
so really this is a human endeavor
in the battle between man versus machine
a computer just came out the victory
deep
mind put its computer program to the
test against one of the brightest
minds in the world and one alphago beat
a professional player
who has 18 go world championships under
his belt
the victor is considered a breakthrough
in artificial intelligence
in research we normally work to produce
an
academic paper it gets published and
maybe we get to talk about it in a
conference if we're lucky
this is not normal for research in fact
i've never experienced
any media attention remotely close to
this
so it's a special moment for us all and
we're just enjoying it while it lasts
[Music]
in a matchup between man and machine who
wins well so far
it's the machine in seoul south korea
the artificially intelligent computer
defeated the global champion in the
ancient chinese board game
go lee sidol lost the first matchup
but he's got four more chances
it is a bit strange being the front
cover and everything as a computer
scientist
normally you sit there in your corner
you could nobody really knows about it
perhaps heard the joke how can you tell
that a computer scientist
is an extrovert and not an introvert if
he's an extrovert he looks at your shoes
when he's talking to you
instead of at his own
like if you look at archer he avoids all
the cameras like
crazy he's like game is finished and
he's like out the back and
back in his room and i think a lot of
computer scientists would be like that
we were more about doing our work than
standing in the spotlight
hello and welcome to game two round two
in the google deepmind challenge
throwdown between
man and machine game one the machine
takes down man huge shock headlines
around the world
the reactions on the ground here from
the folks in korea were just stunned
they estimate 60 million people watch
the game in china
alone probably bringing up to maybe 80
million people watch this game worldwide
it was just incredible and if anything
today is probably
even more of a bad house so he said i'll
knows today he knows that this is just a
really important game right he's got to
win
[Music]
i think probably looking for a little uh
a little payback
my impression is that maybe he
underestimated alphago
and he's going to change his tactics
oh well if i
say anything about alphago that it's not
normal it's maybe the way it handles
a game when it thinks it is ahead yes
we're actually going to have a visit
from one of the team
and we'll talk about exactly that point
from the inside thanks so much for
coming by thor i really appreciate it
can you sort of share a bit of what is
going on
in alphago so alphago has these three
main components there's the policy
network
which was trained on high-level games
to imitate those players and then we
have a second component we call this the
value net
and it can evaluate the board position
and say what is the probability of
winning
in this particular position and then
third component
is the tree search where it would look
through
different variations of the game and try
to figure out what will happen in the
future
so if we now take a position like this
first the policy network would
scan the position and come up
with what would be the interesting spot
to play
and it builds up a tree of variations
and it then employs this value net that
tells it
how promising is the outcome of this
particular
variation
so alphago tries to maximize its
probability of winning
but it doesn't care at all about the
margin by which it wins
okay so when you see a slow looking move
that's maybe an indication that alphago
thinks it has a good chance to win
yeah that is a little giveaway
we're looking for a hotel
[Music]
foreign
ooh looks like uh looks like lee is
taking a little bit of a break
lisa dal go to smoke and alva go just
play it don't sing about the opening
will be zero or not
so i jab sees alphago plays the move 37
and aja puts the stone in the board
that's a very that's a very surprising
move i thought
i thought it was i thought it was a
mistake
when i see this move for me it's just
the big shock
what normally humans will never play
this one
because it's bad it's just bad we don't
know why it's bad
but it's a little bit high yeah it's
fifth line normally you don't make a
shoulder here on the fifth line
um so coming on top of a fourth line
zone is really unusual
yeah that's an exciting move i i think
we've seen an original move here
that's the kind of move uh that that you
play go for
hey
interesting stuff this fifth line
shoulder head is that
yeah i wasn't expecting that um i don't
really know if it's a good or bad move
at this point
the professional commentators almost
unanimously said that
not a single human player would have
chosen move 37.
so i actually had a poke around in
alphago to see what alphago
thought and alphago actually agreed with
that assessment
alphago said there was a 1 in 10 000
probability
that move 37 would have been played by a
human player so it knew that this was an
extremely unlikely move
it went beyond its human guide
and it came up with something new and
creative and different
i am very much watching the game
through these commentators that's the
way it works so when they're confused
i'm certainly confused
at the same time i'm latching on to the
fact that they are confused right that
is that is an interesting moment
when everyone else is confused who's not
confused right besides the machine
i want to see lisa dal when he sees this
he's back lee is back
[Music]
foreign
normally have seen about one two minutes
no more
but this time it think more than two
minutes
[Music]
the more i see this move i feel
something changed
maybe for human we think it's bad but
for alphago
why not go is like geopolitics like
something small that happens here can
have a ripple effect
hours down down the road in a different
part of the board
the game kind of turned on its axis at
that moment
this move is very special because with
this move
all the stone played before is work
together
it's connect it look like a network link
everywhere
it's very special very special
points
this is a tough game for lisa alphago is
just not
letting lisa do what he wants right
black hat's almost
50 points that's a lot that's not a good
sign
oh he said all just slapped himself on
the side of the head
oh wow i think black's ahead at this
point
it's looking good and we're not steady
steady path now
i just see lucidal he lose so much
normally we resent people long time ago
but he won't try
he played he played he played he just
don't want to reason
[Music]
because then white oh he resigned it
looks like
lisa dole has just resigned
there was this heavy sadness over that
whole floor
you could feel it during the game i felt
during the game and
i'm leaving the commentary room to go to
the press conference and i was stopped
by someone
another technology reporter now at first
all he wanted to talk about was the
technology and how great this was but
then even he kind of slipped into this
moment of melancholy where he was upset
as well
i am quite speechless i admit that it
was a very clear loss
on my part from the very beginning of
the game that was not a moment in time
that i felt that i was leading
the game you feel elated and you feel
a little bit scared there is something i
i think frightening to people about
a machine that learns on its own for us
alphago is obviously just
some computer program but looking at the
commentary on the internet
i already saw the commentators call
alphago like he
and she during the games completely
unconsciously
which alphago is really a very very
simple program it's not
anywhere close to full ai and we already
see that happening so i found that very
interesting
the tendency to anthropomorphize ai
systems is
one of the big obstacles in the way of
actually trying to understand how
ai might impact the world in the future
for example the conversation is about
what what could go wrong like what the
risks are then in invariably you see
this terminator picture
every single time there are these red
glowing eyes right we're really closer
to a smart washing machine
than terminator if you look at today's
ai we are really very nascent
i'm extremely excited and passionate
about ai's potential
but ai is still very limited in its
power
i think that people are right to think
that there is a danger that as
we continue to improve these systems
that we might miss that that threshold
where where we do cross
over into danger but the good news is
there are already people thinking about
those dangers
you know there's a lot of talk now we're
leading the discussions on this that
maybe there should be a kind of
cross-industry best practices working
group or something
where the leaders of the research teams
in those organizations the you know the
big ones that are working on ai ibm
microsoft so on
uh come together and make sure that ai's
used ethically and responsibly
i think what is important is that there
is this community of people
who are leading uh the cutting edge of
ai
who are interact with academics and
already are thinking about the long term
and how we can ensure that innovation is
responsible
as the power of these machines gets even
greater
this is it folks day three
game three lease it all go master
back to the wall he's down 2-0
he's got to win today to keep hope alive
to console him and to review africa
console him do you think he's
he's upset or i mean i mean is upset
yeah
in the beginning there was a fearful
fight and then avago
played very well so he secured a very
early lead
from mu 50 the win rate was very high
already
and it was climbing toward 100 percent
oh that's a great move what's your
what's your probability um
uh the shape blue for white
[Music]
he tried to fight directly in the game
but it's not half stale
when we change our style to play with
opponent
normally it's very very bad
so is the game more easy for
alphago it's looking good for us locally
i think the black group is huge and it's
got nowhere to go
and it's going to be running around
[Music]
i don't know how to describe the
situation
if i were black i will resign we should
admit
that we are facing the strongest
existence ever
ever in the gold history there's no
point in playing out the end game
and you're gonna you know you're gonna
lose right so
even if black can live there oh he
resigned
okay wow wow
you saw history made here tonight
alphago is one again three straight wins
three straight wins has won the match
when lisa is on the game he he looked
like unhappy
it's not just he lose the torment it's
just especially about this game
because he don't play his game
i'm very hard about this very
but i can do nothing
you know certainly i feel a bit
ambivalent about it given i'm a games
player and you know go is the pinnacle
of board games
but i really like this statement one of
the top chinese professionals said of
you know if alpha go wins maybe we'll
really start to get to see what this
game's about
i couldn't celebrate it was fantastic
that we'd won
but there was such a big part of me that
saw this man
trying so hard and being
so disappointed
i see internet many many people are
talking about the listener
maybe i don't play the best you know we
are go player
okay sometime in china in korean japan
we see go
like ah we are artists you know we play
ours best right for go right so please
gentle with lisa doll
he's very very good players great
players
i am in the room i see this door he
won't win
i try everything we just we can't
justice
foreign
um
[Music]
you could see that he was more relaxed
after he had lost three games in a row
that said the stakes were still high you
know in the end
it isn't about pride they don't feel
like confidence but they feel light
can lee saddam find alphago's weakness
is there in fact a weakness i was
thinking i just pulled a plug
you just pull the plot out everyone's
still cheering for this at all
and then yeah it's not going very well
now concerned
it feels pretty good for for black at
this point
it feels pretty good for black guys i
want
eliza play his game because for the
moment
he tried many many things to play with
alphago to understand alphago but he
never tried to play
himself i thought man maintained alphago
look like the real mirror when you play
with alphago
you feel very strange look like
you and all the turn naked the first
time you see this
you want to see because oh it's me real
me
and more than more you need accept oh
it's a real me so how now how i can do
it's developing into a very very
dangerous fight
this is really lisado's type of game he
likes this kind of fight
white has to find something inside
black's territory i think he is already
planning on trying something
so you believe in ethereum's ability to
live in the very small
area right yes yes there is a little
potential there
and i think maybe he's going to try to
do something he said all magic
oh what would be the magic move lisa
he's running short on time but he's
going to have to use up all this time
there he just burned like seven or eight
minutes just on this move already
i don't see anything we can't
find anything
what is lisa doll up to here yeah he's
really concentrating
he really is look at look at that lisa
is very patient
he wait he wait away this moment
i feel something look like the wolf
wheat in the forest in the winter
he cold i feel very very cold but i need
patience but the moment coming
they go out to attack
this is the hinge of the game oh
look at that move that's an exciting
move no basically oh he found the wedge
whoa it's going to change the equation
because now black cannot escape
that would be so cool if that works
alphago has just played something maybe
unusual
you know i'm not actually sure what
alphago is trying to do here
what's that about uh you don't really
understand it well well
that was a sharp drop in
this could be that it actually can't
find a way through
i think this is far enough ahead to see
that it doesn't work and now maybe it's
on tilt i don't know
it looks like it's like a viewer
yeah it's made a mistake did anything
strange happen in there
no it'll look normal well there we go
well we can definitely say well there's
a weakness
would we definitely say the mistake
i felt this mixture of this sinking
feeling in my stomach where i was
wondering
if alphago was becoming delusional in
this situation where i could see that it
was starting to play strangely
and at the same time relief of lucidal
that he was actually
in with a chance now i just like trying
not to look horrified
i knew after moved 17 after like
10 or 20 moves i saw avago
strange moves and i know abago somehow
became crazy but i didn't realize why
when i was playing we searched for 90.
at that point okay
i think there's something went wrong
that's the longest research entire game
business
yeah i think it's like his search so
i do get the impression that alphago has
sort of gone off on a tangent
what are you doing well maybe it has a
master plan
no he doesn't even think it has does it
so it knows it's made
because it starts it starts evaluating
it the other way
look look at lisa's confused i was like
what is he doing that's not uh i'm
scared confused that's uh what is it
doing
why is it going you know you asked if it
was a bug
i i've i've said before that if if yeah
right
if deepmind has figured out how to write
code that doesn't have bugs
that is a bigger news story than alphago
oh you're kidding me
hmm there's literally this next movie
we're gonna play
i think i think they're gonna laugh
maybe he's gonna laugh
oh
i don't really know what alphago is
trying to do here
that's the understatement of the year is
it love
nope that's the move hong makes no
misclips
is very confused these are not human
moves
this move also um sort of inexplicable
i mean those you can you can clearly
call those
mistakes yes of course but it's the
first time in the in the four matches
that we've seen moves like that right
oh the value dropped even more it's
weird
we're like 45
[Music]
lights and white white swinging
come on at least at all this is
unbelievable
all right i was so confident that this
black moya would just be consolidated by
black and there's nothing there and
somehow
he's just erased it all like it's gone
so he's found his weakness
that that wedge move probably surprised
him yeah right
yeah alphago seemed to have such a good
game and then
all this whole sequence in the center uh
sort of changed that
he pulls off a miracle he manages to
make it so complicated that the
artificial intelligence
doesn't evaluate it correctly i think it
looks like aj huang
maybe sitting there also knows that the
game is over
i can't i can't not stop smiling
did he smile no i haven't seen him smile
yet
i think he is still checking he's so
serious
he wants to be careful yeah is he
concerned
a lot she really does his best i think
he feels some
something like you know uh
responsibility
or burden too much
[Music]
looks like alphago is resigned wow
the most amazing game um
i'm almost going to tear up was it was
was game four
where he comes back and wins right
[Music]
[Applause]
them
[Music]
foreign
i heard from so many people saying you
know they were
running out in the street they were so
happy you know they were chanting
they're
celebrating especially after a 0-3 down
at the time it seems to be hopeless that
the end of the world is coming
but we see the light usually
i'm happy when i win not like my
colleague wins
but this time it felt like my window
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
my question is about number 78 move
chinese taco player kuli said it was a
god's play
what were you thinking when you made
that
[Laughter]
foreign
does leave me a little bit in awe of the
human brain's power in particular lee's
amazing ability to
cause alphago problems and find
something seemingly out of nothing
and so we really want to understand what
happened so it really was lee's move
that the key is the center if the center
go on there's notions
we were winning before but if alphago
thought it's winning and he
couldn't convert that win that means it
wasn't actually winning otherwise it
would have had the right responses
would we have played it there's a steal
in there what probability does it give
it
[Music]
0.007
is that in the position that he played
that's when he played nicely
so we thought this was the one yeah the
value is really low
so the god move was literally a god move
because we believe that only one in ten
thousands
uh humans would have found that that's
right it doesn't come to mind it's
the top five in the top five moves that
you would consider and i said lisa doll
he said it was the only thing
and he thought it was the only one yeah
welcome back to the four
seasons world champion lisa doll went
looking
for alphago's weakness in game four
and he found it today last round
he's looking to see if he can repeat
that we'll see what happens
the place is a mad house downstairs
maybe as many if not more journalists
here today than there were for game one
we all were really excited for the fifth
match to see what would happen was this
going to be a 3-2
thing or was it going to be a 4-1 thing
and you know there's a different message
with both of those
for me i don't think alphago will make
the mistake again
but who knows maybe it will tell me
and the licital have now have more
confidence about this
look like maybe lizzita finds a key
to open the alphago
you weren't crazy about the timing on
this move yeah yeah
and now you don't approve of this yeah
i'm sort of thinking that maybe alphago
hasn't recovered from game four yet yeah
so
white has to do something about this one
here afterwards no hope he doesn't
know he needs to play though
play some move is bad
i feel something oh maybe this victim is
come back again
are we seeing another short circuit or
is there something
what's uh i think it could be a kind of
a misreading uh
and we're you're pretty comfortable with
saying that
you're doing good for at least good for
at least no
there's no reason for white to be
playing that move it's a bad move
and in some cases it's going to lose a
point too
it is exactly the same 91
certainly someone was telling me that
maybe
the whole game we thought that alphago
was wrong about the board position we
were super worried that
oh i was going to play garbage is going
to be like loose in a very embarrassing
way
and this continues for the whole game
but this is a big weird
time when did they play
yeah as it turned out none of us know go
well enough
to accurately judge what alphago is
doing well why is sweden now
this one looks like white is winning ah
we all say some of our pago moves are
so weird and strange and baby mistakes
but after a game is finished
we have to doubt ourselves our judgement
alphago making another kind of
nonsensical throw-in
we're not really sure what that's about
this is what 10 or maybe 11. play
looks like it looks weird and we don't
quite understand it
i think it is important to study
more about hypogo's mistake like moves
then maybe we can adjust our knowledge
about go
to me the most amazing thing to come out
of my understanding of go
as a result of watching alphago play are
the the infamous
slack moves well there's something
strange about the way it's playing
because it's playing some moves that are
not
really necessary right a slack move is a
move that looks
lazy you can see these other better
moves and alvago is rejecting them but
what i think alphago is teaching us is
that
we've been using score as a proxy
for chance of winning so the bigger my
margin
of territory the more confident i am
that i'm gonna win
and alphago saying no no it shouldn't
matter how much you win by
you only need to win by a single point
why should i be
seizing all this extra territory when i
don't need it the lessons that alphago
is teaching us
are going to influence how go is played
for the next thousand years am i
counting why won this game
how by how much are we talking two
points
[Music]
go is just a game but we can learn
important lessons
from our computer be so successful at go
machines will have the capability
not only to crunch through huge amount
of data
but also to analyze it intelligently
just as
in the case of the go games the machine
made moves that
surprised even the experts and
eventually the machines will gain our
confidence because we will see that very
very often
they make a better guess than we could
have made as humans
i think white might have a slight
advantage here
that's what she said
is
um
[Applause]
i mean i think it's just really is uh
once in a lifetime thing
i would say it's the it's the most
amazing thing yeah i've experienced
you know for us it's the culmination of
20-year dream
it started as a pure research
endeavor we just wanted to understand
can neural networks play the game of go
and from there it went on to a level
that i never expected and i'm
unbelievably proud of the team
when i started doing artificial
intelligence it was
four or five years ago and i was really
interested in that but like many people
would discourage me and they would say
okay there is no future
so actually seeing that within five
years
we are at this stage right now it's
amazing by itself
there are so many possible application
domains where creativity
in a different dimension to what humans
could do could be immensely valuable to
us
and i'd just love to have more of those
moments where we look back and say yeah
that was just like move 37
something beautiful occurred there at
least in a broad sense move 37 begat
move 78 begat a new attitude at least
a new way of seeing the game he
improved through this machine
his humanness was expanded after playing
this
inanimate creation and the hope is that
that machine and in particular the
technologies behind it can have the same
effect
with all of us i remember hearing a talk
by kasparov
who says that a good human plus a
machine
is the best combination this
is a unique experience nobody can have
this experience
play with alphago fight games like this
so
i hope lisador can find something in
this five game
maybe some change in his game
i see today i fight fight fight
it's very good big master real big
master
even though
i
[Music]
me
is done but for all the
story maybe it's just the beginning we
don't know
it's just when i play with alphago he
showed me something
i feel beautiful just it
i see the world different before
everything begins what is
real thing inside the go game with this
thing
i will change something with my game
maybe he just can show humans something
we never discovered
maybe it's beautiful
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you